-Welcome back to the show, everybody.
The Super Bowl was last night, and now Tariq and I both have
a bunch of leftovers that we don't want to waste,
so we've challenged each other to come up with the best dish
using only Super Bowl leftovers.
It's time for the "Super Bowl Leftovers Challenge."
-♪ Super Bowl Leftovers Challenge, yeah ♪
-Whoever makes the most delicious dish
gets to take home the Golden Buffalo Wing.
Tariq, what would this honor mean to you?
-Absolutely nothing, Jimmy.
-Now, we are not doing this alone.
We're each getting help from an amazing New York City chef.
He's the host of "Cook at All Costs" on Netflix
and the owner of the Filipino taquerias Flip Sigi.
His new restaurant, Carriage House,
opens this spring.
Please welcome Chef Jordan Andino.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Chef Jordan Andino. Good to see you, bud.
-What up, what up? -Thank you, Chef. Alright.
-Let's go! -Here's how this works.
We have to use at least three of these leftovers
and make something good out of it, okay?
And as soon as we hear this sound...
[ Rasta horn blares ]
...that means it's a dance party.
No, that means we have a minute left.
So, once we're done, our dishes will be judged by Questlove.
We have placed him in an isolation room.
Quest, please put on the dome of silence
so that you can neither see or hear anything.
It's right there.
Jordan, any advice before we start?
-Oh, yeah, I was having a little convo here. Yes.
-That doesn't seem fair.
[ Laughter ]
But whatever. Wow. That's the way we're gonna play it, huh?
-A little advice. Take your time, have fun with it,
and keep in mind I'm going to be there to help both of y'all.
-Both of us? -Yeah, I'm going to be jumping
back and forth.
-You seem pretty chatty with Tariq already.
Wait. How come mine says "Jimmy"?
What does yours say? -GOAT. GOAT, Jimmy.
-Wait. I have one, too. I have one, too. Wait.
Mine -- I just want to get ready with you guys.
-Yeah, of course. You have an apron. Good.
-Yeah. We're ready. -Okay.
-Does it say something? -No, no.
Mine just is blue. I'm just ready to --
Ready to go. -Alright. Alright.
Don't set us up for something that doesn't pay off.
-Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. -Alright. Here we go.
On the count of "three," let's start cooking.
One, two, three. What are you grabbing?
-Go, go, go.
-Alright. I'm gonna go -- -What are you doing?
-Come on. -Chef, help me out.
-Okay. Go. -I have an idea.
I want to make tater tots on that waffle iron.
-Okay. Genius. -And make a tater-tot waffle.
-That's amazing. -Does that sound good?
-Oil both sides. -So what do we put on that?
I was thinking chicken tenders. -Chicken tenders?
But that's, like, fried on fried.
So something bright. Something bright.
-Something bright? -Right. Like, some of this.
-Pizza? Cheese? -Some of the guac.
-[ Muttering ] No chicken at all.
Help Tariq out. He's making chips.
[ Laughter ]
Chips and dip for Tariq.
-Yeah, I'm just gonna -- Excuse me.
-What -- Are you eating? You got to be making stuff.
You're not at my party, dude.
[ Laughter ]
We're not at the party. Oh, maybe -- How about chili?
Should I put chili and cheese on it?
-Chili would be good. Chili would be good.
Oh, actually, I guess the tenders.
The tenders with the sauce?
-Wait. Tenders -- -Fried chicken and waffles?
Chicken and waffles. -If I cut the chicken tenders?
-Yeah, yeah, make a sauce. Make a sauce. Here, here.
-What do you mean, make a sauce?
-Make a sauce. Make a sauce. -With the chicken tenders?!
-Make a sauce.
-Stop yelling "make a sauce" at me!
[ Rasta horn blares ]
-Ohh! -Oh, that's a minute.
Don't cut yourself. There you go. Put it in. Okay.
-What is Tariq doing? He's just eating!
This is ridiculous.
-You have to taste it. You have to taste it.
-How's it taste? -That's good.
-I kept it simple, man. What you got going over here?
-Don't worry about what's going down over here, man!
-Ready, ready, ready? -Yes. What do I do?
-It's a little hot. It's hot.
-Alright. What do we do?
[ Laughter ] -Go under, go under.
♪♪
-Alright. Chef, thank you so much for your help.
[ Laughter ]
-Toss it, toss it, toss it, toss it.
-Alright.
Alright. Here we go. Alright. Good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Na-cheese-mo. -Na-cheese-mo.
-What did you do? What --
-It's -- Okay.
I layered up the seven-layer dip,
the artichoke dip, a little guac on the side.
-Yeah, amazing. I don't know how you thought of this.
Putting stuff on top.
You're a real culinary genius. Alright.
Tariq, do you want dish one or dish two?
-Dish one. One, obviously.
-No. I'll do dish two, man. -Thank you.
The GOAT spot.
-Is it now time?
Quest may now exit the isolation room.
Can you take the dome --
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Yes. Take it off. Yes. This is --
I don't want you falling.
It's me. It's me. It's me.
Alright. Dude, sorry. Alright. Here you go.
You're right there. Quest.
Questlove. Welcome back to the show, by the way.
Great job on all the stuff
you've done in your whole career.
What a great career.
Chef, do you want to explain what the first one is
and what the second one is?
-Yeah, so, the first dish, dish one, is Na-cheese-mo.
It's, like, 12 layers of nachos and chips and deliciousness.
-Okay.
-How'd we do? Yeah.
Uh, dish two...
[ Laughter ]
-What? -Dish two is a tater-tot waffle.
It's, like, fried chicken and waffles,
so tater-tot waffle with Sriracha honey.
-This is a waffle? -Yeah.
-Okay. Where do I start?
-Start with the chips and guac.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't trust that.
I'm gonna start with this first.
-Ooh. Okay.
♪♪
Ooh, honey and Sriracha.
Whoever did this is an immaculate artist
because even the presentation is, like, on point.
-Yeah, it's like a Picasso over there.
-No, no.
-What does it taste like? Chips and dip?
[ Laughter ]
-I think I'm ready to make my decision.
-Alright. We're ready for the decision.
Quest, please write down. Very important.
Who won the Golden Wing?
Write it down and make sure you put it in the ballot box.
This is a decision --
I'm shaking. Alright. -Alright.
-Now that you've put it in the box,
Quest, can you take it out of the box?
-Now I got to take it out of the box?
[ Laughter ]
-And reveal -- reveal --
I just want to make sure there's no tampering!
No tampering. Take it out of the box.
-I could have just easily told you which one I like better.
-It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter.
Now we know -- Now we know that no one tampered with the result.
[ Laughter ]
-The winner of the Super Bowl Leftover Challenge is...
I like dish one.
-Whoo-hoo-hoo!
-One. One.
-Come on, man.
-A tater-tot waffle?
-Philly! Philly! This is for you!
E-A-G-L-E-S!
Eagles!
-Congratulations to the Super Bowl Leftovers Challenge
winner, Tariq Trotter. -♪ Fly, Eagles, fly ♪
-Thanks again to Chef Jordan Andino. Stick around.
We'll be right back with more "Tonight Show," everybody.
-We did it, baby! We did it! I'm taking this one home!